the jurogan experience
do you think that the algorithms are
designed
to do this or do you think that it's
just a function of human nature that we
tend to
gravitate towards things that outrage us
and then
huddle up together in echo chambers that
this is just a natural tribal behavior
and that what the algorithms do is
essentially just
highlight what we're really interested
in they magnify it in a feedback loop
right so
you're right to say that humans do have
these trades um you know and i haven't
designed the algorithms but i've also
talked to people who have and you know a
lot of they don't even understand
how they work at a certain point like
they're off to the races have you seen
the social dilemma yeah yeah what would
you think about that it's great it's
great right yeah yeah um and it's scary
too
the conclusions that they draw oh
certainly i mean i yeah i made a film
about eight years ago called terms and
conditions may apply
you know and that that came out right
before
the edward snowden revelations you know
when it came out peop the initial
response was like oh this is maybe
conspiratorial surely the government
doesn't have this much
insight into our behavior and
you know and access to
um
to our devices and our personal
information and then the snowden
revelations came out and then it was
like oh well maybe the series didn't go
far enough
um you know and i uh
and back then we had talked about the
idea of how how is technology
influencing us how is it changing us
manipulating us and it didn't feel like
that was the biggest story at the time
and this question of privacy and how our
rights are being eroded through these
agreements that nobody ever really reads
and you could find all kinds of uh juicy
tidbits hidden in there in terms of what
the companies were actually doing and
kind of revealing this unholy collusion
between the government and
and big tech
you know but uh
it at the time people would often say
well what's the cost you know what's the
big deal if they're mining my personal
data to serve me with ads and i'd say
that
the environment we find ourselves in now
is the cost
do you do anything to personally protect
your data do you like use duckduckgo for
searches and things along those lines
you brave as a browser like do you do
that stuff all that yeah yeah use signal
vpns
vpns i mean i i
do my best you know to if a government
actor really wants to
get at you they're going to be able to
yeah i mean you saw the nso clickless
spyware story right yes i mean if if
there's a zero day that allows you to
get access to a microphone and
everything that someone's doing on their
phone without them even having to click
on a link you know it's game over
of course governments
will abuse that
yeah and probably are right now probably
all right now yeah yeah where are phones
at right there
yeah it's um it's interesting because
you would think that there would be a
market for
a platform
that becomes bulletproof and there have
been some you know linux based uh cell
phone operating system phones that they
sell like they buy a phone you get a
google phone they de-google it and put
different software on it and stuff but
i'm not sure
if that's like
if you're deluding yourself into
believing that you're actually protected
with that stuff where you're actually
are protected right i would think they
could work around all those things
especially something that's
i mean it's essentially like open source
right like you like if it's a linux
based
operating system
there's some super geniuses out there
i'm sure they're gonna be able to hack
into that
yeah i mean i think with stuff like
signal you're just you're just
protecting yourself as best you can
right you use something that's that's
end and encrypted you're doing better
than 99 of people who are out there
you're making somebody really have to
work to get access to your to your to
your stuff and if you're using a vpn and
you're using duckduckgo then you're
minimizing your digital footprint and
you're not as you're not worth as much
of these companies and they're not able
to
to you know
manipulate you i guess in the same way
through these algos but let me ask you
this i mean would you what would you do
about the algorithm problem right
because on the one hand algorithms are
necessary for something like a search
engine on the other hand um you know
they're they drive the most sensational
content things like q and on um
and uh and i think have largely
facilitated the situation we find
ourselves in now watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify